if you could sit down with vladimir
putin
and ask him a question or talk to him
about an idea
what would you say
i would walk out of the room
just as with almost any other leader
i know what he's going to say i read the
party line i read his pronouncements
doesn't want to hear from me
am i going to say
why did you carry out a crime that's
comparable to the us invasion of iraq
and
the stalin hitler invasion of poland am
i going to ask that question
if i met with
john f kennedy
state
would ask
why did you radically escalate the war
in vietnam
launch the u.s air force start
authorizing a bomb
drive
launch programs to drive
villagers who you know are supporting
the national liberation front drive them
into concentration camps
to separate them from the forces the
defending would have asked him that
of course not
do you think the people who led us into
the war in vietnam
the war in afghanistan and iraq
the war in
ukraine
are evil
i mean
it's very hard to be in a position of
leadership
of a
violent aggressive power
without carrying out evil acts
are the people evil
i mean
i'm not their moral advisors
i don't know anything about them i look
at their actions their statements their
policies
evaluate those
their families can evaluate their
personalities
you